hello everyone and welcome back to
another very nice game from round one of
the air things masters 2022 it's magnus
carlsen versus vladislav artemyev and
it's quite quite an enjoyable game as
let's dive straight into it magnus with
the white pieces opens with g3 so here
he's saying that he wants to just play
chess he's not interested in a
theoretical debate or anything uh it's
the first round let's see let's see uh
you know how everyone is doing so here
we have knight to f6 bishop to g2 and d5
now by artemy of knight to f3 and the g6
we have castles bishop to g7 and now c4
striking against the black is a very
strong central pawn we have d captures
on c4 accepting this pawn and now magnus
goes for knight day three he's ready to
recapture with knight captures on c4 uh
we have castles uh in the now knight
captures on c4 we have c5 now uh and
here there are a couple of games with d3
d4 is also a known move knight after e5
is a known but the move magnus plays b3
uh is a new move so now already as of
move 8 we have a completely new game
saying that you don't have any useful
discoveries here not a lot of good jumps
for the night so you don't have to
really worry about this so here artemive
just continues developing knight to c6
and the bishop to b2 magnus fianchettos
the other bishop as well
and now we have bishop to e6 for the
moment uh
hindering the development of the e pawn
but you you don't want to push it
anywhere just yet so here we have rook
to c1 a continuing development and rook
to c8 we have d3 by magnus and b6 now uh
queen to d2 and now queen to d7 black
also develops the queen connects the
rooks with rook after d1 and now rook f2
d8 uh going after bishop to h3
right now would be maybe a little bit
too soon uh as knight f to e5 could be
very very annoying or even uh knight c
the e5 the other knight also can attack
the queen let's say captures captures
you can play queen e6 but still if you
don't know what's happening maybe you
don't want to spend time on it as it is
a rapid game so here uh artemy just
continues developing rook f2d8 and now
magnus goes for this very nice jump
knight after e5 going after the queen
captures an e5 captures an e5 and queen
to d6 and now magnus shows us the
importance of always pushing that b pawn
and he plays b4 and what's the idea
behind this pawn push it seems like
you're just giving up a pawn
but if black black accepts this uh then
it could be all over very quickly for
example pawn captures here now magnus
plays knight c6 and now attacks this
rook this pawn this pawn and let's say
the black defends the a7 pawn just
bishop to e5 and black's queen is
trapped so there are all uh
sorts of tricky ideas in the position so
instead after b4 we have knight to d7 uh
uh artemia figures that there's
something uh suspicious happening here
so we want to trade pieces now knight
captures on d7 bishop captures on b2
bishop queen captures bishop on b2
bishop captures on d7 and now b captures
on c5 uh this is uh uh why the b4 pawn
was uh the the b4 push was very strong
because now after rook captures on c5
rogue characters we have queen captures
and now we have well a very strong
d-pawn here the bishop is very nicely
placed and the rook can come to c1 but
well this is all very nice
it's not all that much here magnus goes
for c1 he grabs the open c file for
himself but after queen d6 there's not
much you can do about rook to c8 so uh
you will not be able to keep control of
the open c file so here magnus tries h4
now comes rook to c8 artemiev just
trades off a pair of rooks with rook
captures bishop captures and now the
material is completely equal both
players have a light square bishop and
now uh it seems like it's uh it's a draw
uh or rather you have to play an equal
endgame against magnus so here we have
d4 magnus now ready to grab the full
center with e4 bishop to d7 now comes e4
now uh having control of all of these
squares we have f6 artemia wants to play
e5 to create some weaknesses as this is
simply too much control uh f4 by magnus
and now e5
asking what do you do here so magnus
trades once and advances the pawn to d5
so while this does give magnus the pass
to deep on it also creates some
weaknesses here this is now a weakness
but uh black is also has his fair share
of weaknesses so here we have a5 it's an
interesting push because the queen of
course guards the b6 pawn and you want
to put your pawns on dark squares as
magnus has a light square bishop and the
problem is
uh black queen will have to keep an eye
on both of these pawns at all times uh
but okay luckily for artemia you don't
really have anywhere else to be so
that's you know the d6 square is
perfectly fine so king h2 by magnus we
have b5 now uh starting to push maybe
artemis even considering creating a past
pawn of his own so bishop to h3 offering
a trade of bishops and going into a
queen endgame and artemia accepts this
bishop captures queen captures and now
artemia pushes b4 uh with ideas of a4
and a3 and maybe later on uh b3 if the
position allows it so queen c2 by magnus
stopping this idea also uh getting ready
to deliver some checks to the black king
now comes queen d7 check king to g2 and
king to f7 uh we have queen to f2 with
check king back to g7 now comes queen to
c5 uh getting the queen to a bit of a
more active square and now artemia is in
a very difficult spot there's only one
good move for him he has to play queen
to a4 put pressure on the a2 pawn and
this is how he
hopes to achieve a draw or maybe if
magnus doesn't play optimally he maybe
even win the game however he played
queen to g4 and it makes sense okay
you're attacking the pawn you're
threatening some checks here uh the
problem is the game is now lost for him
but you have to find the absolute uh uh
the absolute exact uh
variation that
allows this and it's uh well it's not
all that easy to spot so feel free to
pause the video and try to find it for
white while i give you a couple of
seconds not adjusted the main move but
also the entire line
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on always being
excellent at everything and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to e7 with check that's the good
stuff and now whatever black plays it's
game over if king h8 this is checkmate
if king g8 we don't care we just deliver
one check and after king g7 we pick up
the e5 pawn with check and now we pretty
much don't care what we play because we
have two connected pass pawns in the
center so the only thing left for
artemy have to do is king to h6 and then
now comes the main line queen to f8
czech king to h5 and now of course queen
to f3 making sure that our d-pawn can
now just run to victory and there's
nothing black can do about it so
artemiev also has a way of counter
countering this he will create a pass
pawn of his own on queen side but d6 we
have b3 uh and now magnus just finds the
absolute nicest when possible he plays
queen capture sanji for king captures on
g4 and only now d7 this is very
important because after this pawn
becomes a queen queen g5 will be
checkmate so it doesn't matter that uh
artemia will also have a queen so b
captures on a2 magnus played the d8
queen and he was in this position on mu
42 that vladislav artemy have resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here once black makes a move and of
course any move other than promoting to
a queen is pretty much pointless queen
g5 will be checkmate so uh great stuff
by by both of them artemis held his own
for most of the game but then at that
moment where he really had to make that
choice of going queen to a4 uh he didn't
find it he played queen to g4 and it was
more than enough for magnus to win this
game uh so yeah uh that's it uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it really
a nice one and uh as a lot of you guys
are interested in this here uh are the
uh the the co2 standings uh as the the
tournament is sponsored by air things
it's a well a device that improves your
quality of living and here you can see
that these are the the co2 standings uh
after round one so you can see that
magnus has the uh absolute best air
quality uh
i'm not saying that that's the only
reason why he was so good but uh
uh
also very very nice to know as it's
quite quite a lot better than um most of
the other players and i've also received
one of these devices and i've been
monitoring my air for the last 10 days
and well it does seem like uh
up until now i was living in a in a
toxic environment so if you guys are uh
interested in what they do or you know
what what uh why are things uh
are even sponsoring the event uh you
know questions like that feel free to
ask them in the in the comment section
and i will answer them maybe in the next
video maybe tomorrow at the end of some
of the the videos so you just use
hashtag airthings and you know i will
try to answer all of your questions if
you guys are interested in that
uh so yeah once again hope you guys uh
enjoyed it i would like to thank all the
alter elites for 45 and non-commercial
ep dale cook under the 95 american flag
numa and david kimura for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this spectacular event uh until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day